hello everyone my name is dr. Miller and
the SCP were going to be studying today
is SCP 27 object class Euclid special
containment procedures the host of SCP
27 currently subject 27 - - is to be
kept in a 5x5 metre containment cell
with a graded raised floor connected to
a strong vacuum system all creatures
removed from the subjects containment
cell are to be incinerated except for a
small portion to be diverted for
analysis and necropsy the cells to be
cleansed and inspected for structural
damage daily subject 27 - - must be
monitored by at least two personnel at
all times any unusual behavior or vital
signs on the part of the subject or the
appearance of any unusual species in the
subjects vicinity must immediately be
reported to level 4 personnel
security personnel assigned to a CP 27
must be inoculated against all known
animal born pathogens and must be armed
with tranquilizer guns with standing
orders to subdue the subject if the need
arises until a CP 27 is better
understood no personnel of level 4
clearance or higher should approach
within 200 metres of the subject
description as CP 27 appears to be a
phenomenon of unknown source that seems
to be tied to one human subject
currently 27 - two at a time as host to
a CB 27 subject 27 - - is constantly
surrounded by swarming vermin that are
drawn to his location the subject does
not appear to be able to assert control
over these creatures in any way and is
in fact prone to occasional attacks from
feral specimens these creatures have
also been known to attack personnel who
approach too closely
wherever the subject goes an initial
swarm of flying insects such as gnats
and flies will start to form a cloud
around him usually within two to three
minutes shortly thereafter crawling
animals including lice cockroaches worms
spiders mice and rats will begin to
appear
the longer the subject remains in a
location the more vermin will gather
there when the subject leaves a location
some of the creatures will follow but
most will disperse SCP 27 has been known
to transfer between hosts once upon the
death of the first known host subject 27
- 1c Appendix 1 for more information
since SCP 27 could likely repeat this
feat upon the death of subject 27 - all
high-level personnel should be kept far
away from the current host until more
about SCP 27 is understood SCP 27 has
also likely transferred between hosts an
unknown number of times before
containment
research into potential previous hosts
has commenced with preliminary evidence
suggesting that SCP 27 may have existed
for at least years it is not yet known
how SCP 27 chooses or attracts animals
or what SCP 27 exactly is the previous
host never expressed having any sort of
communication with a separate conscious
entity analysis of the current host has
been inconclusive at best Appendix one
timeline of significant events April
1990 subject 27 - 1 is discovered in an
abandoned warehouse outside that have
been completely overrun by rats
cockroaches and other vermin and is
contained in catalogued as SCP 27 the
subject is described as a Caucasian male
in his late thirties of average height
but gaunt filthy and curd and bites and
scratches the subject also shows
symptoms of degraded mental health
evidence of heavy use of alcohol and
illicit drugs and signs of prolonged
sleep deprivation October 2000 subject
expires autopsy shows more than 70% of
the subjects body
a colony of rats nesting in the subjects
abdomen for at least generations October
mm between 140 and 150 hours after the
subjects death security officer kept
reports being awoken by breathing
problems due to a large house fly having
crawled up his nose later shown to of
lame eggs subsequent observations lead
to categorization of officer as subject
27 - to the original host is
reclassified as subject 27 - 1 and SCP
27 is redefined appendix 2 recording of
interview 27 - 2 0 1 the following
interview was conducted on October 3
2005 shortly after subject 27 - 2 was
identified and transferred to the
containment cell that at house subject
27 - 1 playing now good morning how are
you feeling scared confused understand
the bond energy I feel like I need to
shower all the damn time but what about
inside do you feel anything different
inside to you like at present No
really noticed anything way you haven't
felt anything different since the
original house died besides the edgy so
that's half what about any sort of
voices or compulsion no I have felt
anything except bunks crawling all over
me I feel dirty scared doc what about me
you gotta get this thing out so I can go
see them yeah of course yeah they're
going to do everything we can to get 27
out of you note shortly after this
interview took place dr. Jamison and
several other members of the research
team for SCP 27 were transferred to the
SCP 1772 project okay and I'm gonna stop
here thank you all for listening and you
were all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
you
gotten used to the feet you never think
about how many feet they have my grip of
your skin hair on your body now they
hold on to you effortlessly
they almost tickle now almost the smell
it's barely noticeable anymore but at
first it was it was pretty bad threw up
a lot then they started crawling into my
mouth when I was trying to eat but then
I realized they didn't mind when I ate I
think that was when I started to come to
terms with it didn't taste good at first
with the crotch insects have a texture
all their own thick sweet and full of my
Hannah what it was like the best thing
I've ever eaten and they didn't even
mind yeah I was just so much I could
reach out and take I think they like to
sing his sleep hard to ignore it when
they get in my ears well everywhere else
do all kinds of things tripping buzzing
around all the time constant noise I
mean it's a lot louder in this summer a
lot not hugger
I don't think I might know just like to
sing it's almost like music
I can see them watching me not the
crawling things the people I know how
you see me even in places were strange
people people who the world forget even
they look going could see it in their
eyes they pity me no other discipline
gross now revolted you two I see you
trying to look me in the eye not the
bits of my hair or my teeth I've seen
that look before you don't want to can't
help but stare I know you can't they
never can it's okay no no can sit back
yeah it's alright your eyes are watery
it's better if you move away of it take
a drink of water or something it will
help your stomach I gave up trying to
wash them off not in a shower or a
bathtub those aren't big enough
not enough water to wash them away but I
didn't try it's just a lost cause at
that scale I mean I still have scars
from scrubbing so hard I started to go
swimming to drown them like the story of
the Pied Piper you know he took the rats
away and drown them in the river I
always loved swimming even before it
gave me that little breath of clean it
then the leeches found me leeches aren't
answer the worst they're so small they
get all over in my hair nose and ears in
my eyes
thousands of them it's just I can't even
I can't even describe it just imagine
every inch of your body um nevermind I'm
sorry I'm sorry
I never even mentioned the rats always
so many but I guess they're not at least
they're warm so many keep me warm in the
cold like a like a fuzzy blanket
Fuzzy's hungary blanket people keep rats
as pets right it's no different
everyone loves bats I love my pets I
love them all I'll never be in low
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Bishop Desmond Hoskins and get
suburi thank you all very much for your
support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos and some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
you